lord if you're out there i need you in
this moment please do not let me fall
with this woman in my head in a show
that has this many epic martial arts
scenes it makes sense that no matter how
many times the scene is rehearsed
there's still a major element of danger
hovering above in this video we'll be
talking about sword fights broken thumbs
cuts bruises falls and trips to the er
buckle up being there and doing it
ourselves
number one things get real in this one
thomas ian griffith has been doing
martial arts since he was a kid so
naturally he's got a lot of experience
with swords i was thinking how are we
going to top all these great karate
fights we've seen a lot of karate so i
walked over to one of the creators and
said what if we did a sword fight i'm
really good at swords he was really
excited that it was going to happen
now
time to find out what you're really made
of
but
also nervous about it at the same time
but then the thing is because i'm so
used to sparring and martial arts you're
putting a weapon in your hand and you're
in character so the danger factor just
went way up luckily no one was actually
harmed but the element of fear was
captured that day that's why the scene
worked so well number two do you
remember him from karate kid 3 his
aggressive fighting style really hasn't
changed much one thing that made
shooting his fight scenes in kobrakai
really difficult for him was the major
shoulder injury he'd been nursing he had
to work with the fight coordinator don
lee on what he physically could and
could not do when it came to
choreographing his scenes he's also no
stranger to onset injuries i can't even
imagine what that's like while filming
karate kid 3 he performed a stunt that
required him to land on his side after
jumping about two feet in the air but
unfortunately it caused some serious
internal issues a few days later after
passing out at a blackjack table in
vegas he had to get surgery after
finding out he only had minutes to live
i'm in the best shape of my life i'm
doing a martial arts film and they're
like we don't know if we can save your
life we're lucky to have him back on set
for cobra kai
number three not the ideal fighting
platform in the prom after-party fight
scene in season four there were a lot of
tricky elements to work around they wet
the concrete so that the the streets
look larger than they are not only was
it 35 degrees outside that night but
they were also trying really hard not to
slip and fall after every move these
ladies too are fighting in either
barefoot on concrete just a bit of movie
magic that can turn any scene into a
dangerous environment high heels on
concrete or like slippery dress shoes
number four not a sound you like to hear
when filming a fight scene as we
mentioned the concrete was very slippery
in this prom after party sequence so at
some point merry mouser and peyton list
had to duck out a frame for a takedown i
went down and i stupidly put my hands
out like this to catch my fall so i had
like my hands spread payton being in
high heels actually fell on top of her
during her duck out fell on my hand and
my thumb would pop and i immediately was
like i broke my thumb did she say
anything about it
no one of the stunt guys heard the sound
of her thumb popping and rushed to her
age look i was a fireman for years i've
heard that sound
that's not good luckily he was able to
pop it back in place and she kept going
on with the scene like nothing happened
number five one of the few stunts jacob
bertrand wasn't allowed to do because
the kick involved wrapping his legs
around his co-star's neck the risk was
way too high for him to perform it
himself basically he jumps up into this
flying triangle and dawn wouldn't let
thomas catch me and throw me on the
ground but pretty much everything else i
got to do number six we're talking glass
a lot of it when johnny and sensei
crease have their epic dojo battle there
was a medic on set super gluing cuts
together cleaning up injuries off the
set and getting them ready to go for
another take the crease stunt double was
barefoot and things like that where
you've got flesh showing and you're
going through glass onto concrete can be
tricky i would say that was probably one
where our guy got banged up the most
nice move
number seven parkour anyone it makes
sense why this would be one of the few
scenes they really needed a stunt person
for i think the only thing i was not
allowed to do was fly between the
buildings but i did get to sprint
towards the jump and roll out of it i
just didn't get to fly over the
buildings that was my super lovely stunt
double silky home she wasn't even
attached to wires wow like why does this
look so accurate like this looks
disturbingly like me she really jumped
that gap she was like oh yeah just
because i study your run i was like what
do you mean you study my run she was
like you don't run normal mary mouser
learned something about her running form
that day oh i think your cat wants to
come in i don't know you had a cat
we don't
number eight definitely not your average
house party this scene was actually
supposed to happen outside but because
of some nasty weather conditions they
had to switch it up last minute to make
it work indoors we had to completely
redesign the fight to make it work
inside the house which made it a lot of
fun because there was so much more stuff
there we could move around that probably
was one of the more difficult ones to
shoot they also did it in just one shot
so getting everything done safely proved
to be a major challenge secret miyagi
pressure points number nine not a fun
day on set for yuji okumoto while
filming the fight scene between daniel
and chosen yuji swung his legs up which
caused him to pull his hamstring
although he kept fighting through the
pain you can see the moment on screen
where he grabs his injured leg you're
having fun at my expense
oh you should have seen your face
number 10 sometimes you forget that it's
coming keeping in mind that the actors
basically do all of their own stunts
there was a particular sequence where
mary mouser and payton list go toe to
toe in the school hallway you kiss
miguel
i like bent backwards just in time and
everybody was like wow you really timed
that perfectly there was actually more
luck involved when it came to timing
that reaction i completely forgot the
kick was coming from my head and i
remembered at the very last second
number 11. we're not surprised but still
in that same fight sequence from season
two merry mouser ended up with a pretty
messed up hand i've had a couple of
injuries all pretty much completely on
my own messed myself up misblocked a
kick and hyper-extended these three
fingers backwards once had to go to the
er but i was all clear all good my hand
is taped and you can actually if you
pause it you can see certain shots or my
fingers are like taped together number
12. just another day at the office i did
i broke my toe when william was
performing fight choreography with
martin cove he sustained quite a few
injuries we're talking pulled hamstrings
and most notably a broken toe his feet
are so big my toe hit his toe i jammed
the toe nobody even knew it went
completely in my foot he kept quiet
about it out of fear that he might be
replaced by his stunt double and i just
yanked it out
it hurt i'm telling you what it was like
a knife that went up
number 13 naturally there are gonna be a
lot in this show when training for the
fight scenes many of the actors didn't
have any prior experience with martial
arts i was covered in bruises just
because we were going and we didn't have
time to think to yourself no pull back
mary mouser found herself getting
accidentally hit a lot because she
wasn't reacting fast enough to her
co-star's punches and kicks we were just
like oh my god what's the next step i'm
begging you
for what
mercy with all the epic stunts and
intense martial arts these actors and
stunt doubles perform it's unsurprising
that none of them make it out unscathed
what was your favorite moment from the
new season
you